you may have heard that ABC canceled its
most popular scripted show yesterday
after a lead actor sent out a series of
bizarre tweets which she later blamed on
sleeping pills you've read about it but
there's at least one upside to the
Roseanne story the left is now on the
record opposing racism attacking people
on the basis of their race is immoral
they're telling us and of course they're
absolutely right about that let's hope
this conversation continues and
progresses liberals may finally concede
the discrimination based on skin color
really is wrong whether it's in hiring
or promotions or government contracting
or school admissions if they admit that
that would be real progress it's not
happening yet though for now American
liberals are still living in that
strange irony free world where it's
possible to denounce racism even as you
commit it that's the same world Al Gore
occupies when he flies private jets to
global warming conferences it's the
place where attorneys general can yell
at you about domestic violence even as
they beat up their girlfriends it's
hypocrisy land that's where liberals
live last night for example MSNBC held a
town hall meeting dedicated to fighting
racism guess who they invited to lecture
America on the topic you guessed it
racists the special was literally
co-hosted by Al Sharpton remember him
he's the guy who ridiculed Jews in New
York as quote diamond dealers he's the
one who denounced a Jewish store owner
as a white interlope or that instigated
a racial Massacre in which a teen eight
people were murdered also on stage last
night was a guy called Tim Wise wise
describes himself as a professional anti
racism activists which ought to be a
tip-off that he himself is a racist
which obviously he is hears wise using
MSNBC's platform to make ugly
generalizations based on skin color
watch this white America has been raised
to believe a the police are always the
good guys and frankly that black lives
matter less than white comfort what you
are saying is my discomfort with you
right now is worth more than the
potential that your life would be
snuffed in 10 minutes wait isn't that
slander against an entire racial
category oh yes
is but let's say you want an even more
nasty racial stereotyping MSNBC is the
channel for you they've got it here's
Tim Wise again keep in mind this is what
liberals are now claiming is the
opposite of racism the gentrify errs of
today their parents or their
grandparents ran away from the city to
get away from black and brown and now
their children and their grandchildren
are saying oh the suburbs there's only
so many olive gardens I can go to so I
need to go back to the city
and get my life in the city but when I
do that I need to have my hot yoga
studio in my pottery studio and my stuff
representative and if you intrude on
that I will then call the police are you
taking notes on this are you are you
getting this they're telling you at
MSNBC that because certain people have
the same skin color they all have the
same dumb attitudes they like the same
crappy restaurants they spend their free
time pursuing the same frivolous hobbies
and by the way they are all every one of
them immoral you can tell by the way
they look that's the official position
of the American left the same people
currently accusing you of racism huh
Christopher Harris's executive director
of unhyphenated American he joins us
tonight mistress what do you make of
that
watching that Tucker there's a lot of
things going on in the world right now
that came to my mind for example what's
happening in Venezuela when Tim was
talking about people trying to gentrify
areas well if you look in Venezuela
right now there are people fleeing a
terrible geopolitical socio-economic
issue and they're going to Trinidad
right you know so they have an influx in
Trinidad of Venezuelans and Trinidad is
trying to implement rules to kind of
push some of them out now most people
know there's a lot of black people in
Venezuela they don't all look like Hugo
Chavez in fact South America got one of
the largest percentages over 50% of the
slaves were taken from Africa were
brought to South America places like
Brazil and Venezuela and every like that
and so here it is you have people who
are black who don't want other people
who are black flooding into their
countries so maybe it's more an economic
issue and I think by the way there are
fair questions to raise about radical
demographic change for sure it it upsets
people and I understand that but to
pretend that it's all about race and
that one race is worse than another race
isn't that the definition of racism
absolutely Tim Wise is going to be able
to pay his rent this month because he's
a racial pimp that's what he is I mean
that's what he does is he travels around
the country going to colleges telling
young white men and young white women
that you are a racist and it's you're a
benefit of white privilege and they go
on and they tell their parents how
terrible they are
because a guy named Tim Wise came to my
college and told me that I have white
privilege and essentially what Tim is
doing is he's assuming a privilege that
quite frankly I don't acknowledge that
he has you know I have zero sense of
inferiority and that's one of those
things that someone like Tim wants me to
believe in fact we might think he wants
you to have a sense absolutely
absolutely and President Bush talked
about it he said it's the soft bigotry
of low expectations yes and that's
what's happening around the world so
what's happening in America that they're
constantly trying to tell young black
men and young black women that you have
no chance in America because of your
pigmentation but no one wants to talk
about the fact that different
demographics all black people are not
African Americans my wife is actually
her parents are from Panama her parents
came here legally with nothing they were
able to climb the socio-economic ladder
both of them attain their degrees both
their daughters attained their degrees
but yet there are people who are you
know I guess some would call me an
african-american I don't answer to that
term I'm an American black person
obviously you can tell by my
pigmentation I'm black but there's lots
of people even in my extended family who
have not attained what some of my
in-laws have attained regardless of the
color of their skin but Tim Wise would
have you to believe that simply because
of the color of your skin you can't be
successful in America and you know what
President Trump
god bless him what he's doing with the
economy right now it's helping black
people where do you think a country
winds up where the official position is
that the races are different some are
more moral than others and basically
they should hate each other I mean that
is the message that a lot of our elites
are pushed out on the rest of us what
does that do to the country it tears it
apart quite frankly they're agents of
chaos is what they are is that they're
there they make their money like mr.
wise by helping to tear people apart
with unhyphenated America when people
ask me what is unhyphenated America so
we are what we sound like we're an
organization that believes that America
is best when it's unhyphenated that if
you if you believe and if you embrace if
you promote the principles of life
liberty and the pursuit of happiness
then you're an American and if there's
no need for any prefix or suffix you're
just an American and that's what needs
to be preached until and taught on our
college campuses instead of having the
the Tim Wise and then Al Sharpton's was
when I was a kid I'm 49 not that old
liberals used to say what you're saying
they don't anymore
thank you that was really nice to hear
in fact you took her I appreciate it